now to the political firestorm over
proposed changes at the cash-strapped
u.s postal service
members of congress are expected to
return to capitol hill today for a rare
saturday session
house democrats are forcing a vote on
their bill to provide
25 billion dollars in emergency funding
for the agency
embattled postmaster general louis de
joy is due to testify before a house
oversight and reform committee on monday
during a senate hearing friday he said
his much criticized cost cutting moves
will not hamper mail-in ballots for the
upcoming election
president trump claims mail-in votes
will cause chaos
ben tracy is at the white house with
more ben good morning
good morning so president trump is
continuing his unfounded attacks on
mail-in voting despite the fact that his
own hand-picked postmaster general says
that he's voted by mail for years
he also says he feels confident the
postal service can handle what is
expected to be a record number of
mail-in ballots
because of the pandemic the postal
service is fully capable and committed
to delivering the nation's election mail
securely and on time postmaster general
louis de joy told the senate homeland
security committee friday
that even ballots and close to election
day will be delivered on time
we will scour every every plant today
you know
each night leading up to election day
very very very confident but de joy a
republican mega donor who took over the
postal service two months ago
has implemented severe cost cutting
moves such as removing hundreds of mail
sorting machines and slashing overtime
which have led to undelivered mail
piling up around the country
delays that come at a time when people
depend on reliable service now
more than ever dejoy says he's not
intentionally slowing down mail to
impact the election and has never
discussed postal service operations
with president trump and the the
insinuation is
quite frankly outrageous dejoy claims
he's now suspending further changes
until after the election
but won't replace machines and mailboxes
that have already been removed
the democrats bill expected to pass the
house today would force him to reverse
those changes
i don't know what's going to happen in a
speech friday inside a packed ballroom
with no
social distancing and few masks
president trump again claimed mail-in
ballots will delay election results
and cause chaos this will be the
greatest catastrophe one of the greatest
catastrophes in the history of our
country that's how serious it is
and they also think i'm trying to steal
an election just the opposite i want the
fair results of an election
the postal service board of governors is
now creating a bipartisan election mail
committee to oversee the postal
service's vote by mail process
they want to make sure all those ballots
are delivered on time
jeff ben thank you very much